when you start a no man's sky or what is
your role within this universe it's an
interesting game because actually we
will show like three minutes of gameplay
like we did need three for most games
that's enough you show a racing game for
three minutes you've seen everything you
need to see right but for us it's like
just the start
and actually a lot is possible in the
game and we don't want to prescribe what
people do right so we're not going to
say this is a game about discovering
creatures we're not going to say this is
a game about killing dinosaurs and we're
not good to say this is a game about
flying a ship or or you know becoming a
fighter and a pirate or bounty hunter or
whatever but loads of those things are
possible not everything is possible and
when we ship the game not everything
will be possible but this is a game I
think we're going to be making for quite
a while you know even after it comes out
is it fair to say that right now that
you guys haven't decided exactly what
those things are as well no actually we
have a really good idea of what it is
and today we're about to tell you
welcome back to the next big game no
man's sky on today's show we're going to
detail what we learned about the
gameplay in hello games is vast universe
and unveiled new details about how the
game might evolve over time is there a
story are there quests can I play with
others all questions you've been asking
but all variations on one really simple
question what exactly do you do in no
man's sky when the game releases every
player who picks up a pad and plays is
going to help us discover a little bit
more and I can't wait
you started the outsider to the galaxy
for a lot of people the simplest way to
describe the game they will be trying to
make a journey to the center of the
galaxy not everyone has to do that as
loads of other ways to play it but
that's something that people will
probably do you can have to upgrade your
ship your weapons your suit you might
gather resources you might take out
other ships you know it's kind of there
you can imagine what kind of gameplay
you're going to have no man sky is a
game about space exploration every
player connects that the game begins on
a planet alone spread across a singular
galaxy in a wider universe your goal to
use your resources to get to the center
of that galaxy the game doesn't end
there but something tells us you're
going to be trying to achieve that goal
for quite a while so how do you do it
you start on a planet without a ship
well the progression in no man's sky is
dictated by resources you can mine from
minerals on a planet surface maybe you
sell those minerals at a space station
to buy yourself a ship might be millions
of light years away from the nearest of
the human player but there's plenty of
AI in the universe of no man's sky trade
vessels colonies space stations many of
whom would probably love to trade with
you many others who probably want you
dead
so you have things like the drones are
we showed you also have a weapon and
we've shown some of that what we want to
get away from so desperately is I play
so many sci-fi games and the weapon is
still an assault rifle or pistol or
whatever it blows my mind it's like a -
the type of sci-fi that we're trying to
do needs to feel futuristic and thinking
back so what you have is kind of like a
and upgradable this sounds really boring
but like a multi-tool that's why people
make assault rifles and battle radically
sound cool we'll call it like a battle
to listen right but you can upgrade it
in various different ways depending on
how you want to place it you're mining
or
more about attacking or being an
aggressor or whatever or scanning
exploring upgrade it in different ways
you know we want that to feel futuristic
and kind of reasonably powerful and kind
of defines almost like your your
character in some ways in that like or
PG way if you get into that and then
your suit as well you upgrade so you'll
upgrade that to have more armor perhaps
or health or survive longer underwater
or in a toxic environment or whatever so
there are you know things like that but
I guess the core gamer is used to
there's space combat it's seamless that
can end up being combat over the surface
of the terrain and and that can also end
up being combat on the terrain a
reasonable number of planets will have a
pretty diverse ecology and on some of
those you have things that you know are
dangerous do you know man sky is a game
without traditional questing if you want
to travel further you have to find the
means to upgrade your ship how you do so
that's where the freedom lies the game
isn't missions or levels or rank the
game is the journey but it's not all
emergent gameplay there are definable
ways that the game will record your
progress - you know I said there's
various different ways to play the game
we will track those various different
ways and within each of those you can
have an idea of status which you can
take as a rank right so you could say I
am the the number one kind of space
pirate or a bounty hunter or whatever or
botanist or Explorer what-have-you but
it does mean that you can play for as
long as you want you can play in various
different ways for as long as you want
you can follow that trail for as long as
you want are you a miner a peaceful
trader a pirate or a bounty hunter what
other professions and activities exist
beyond those hello games aren't really
willing to give us an answer just yet
but you can use your imagination maybe
you could just travel around taking
photographs of the creatures you
discover or perhaps try and upgrade your
suit so you can reach the deepest ever
ocean or maybe you just want to spend
your time attacking the main antagonists
of the game Sean confirm that there is a
malevolent force in the universe but
what
is there not willing to say we kind of
have something that we haven't talked
about which is like an antagonist on the
on our you know in the university can
become malevolent for something that
drives a lot of combat on the on the
ground
another question that keeps on coming up
is is there multiplayer I mean no man
sky is a game that takes all its players
and throws them on to opposite sides of
a vast to scale galaxy can you ever meet
those players and can you play with them
this is not a game about forming plan or
allegiances whatever right and but it
has some MMO esque hammocks I guess in
terms of meeting other people place is
so vast that's that's what you can't get
across to people you know they're like
it starts off all unexplored the entire
kind of universe and then as each person
visits a place that will upload that
information or visit a planet or
whatever everyone always has to be like
after a week one everything be kind of
discovered if you took one of our
planets like some of our planets our
planet sized you know and you drop a
million people onto a planet the size of
Earth right we're still going to be
really far apart so probably even one of
our planets won't ever get fully
discovered in the trailer as well
there's a you can see I guess what you
called wingmen other people with you can
you talk about what that is are they a I
that are a lot so in in the trailer they
were a I and you can cross paths with
other players it's just not a core
component of the game you're not going
out seeking them out or whatever but
it's lovely to play and just see a
little touch of the arm playing with
other people you and your friends you
know we're doing the worst possible
thing probably we're going to fling you
out you know really far apart there is
this thing which I'm not going to talk
about now that is a plan for multiplayer
and for people to have a more
traditional multiplayer experience
within the game and and that's something
that we'll deal with further down the
line that is exciting but that is not
what's core to the game right now I'm
sure many of you are salivating at the
idea of an expanded multiplayer mode but
it's clear hello games aren't trying to
make a deathmatch gain or I'm MMO
at least not at launch you'll be able to
meet other players but just how involved
those counters will be is still unknown
it seems hello games are trying to craft
an experience that's at its most
powerful played alone
you start on in a galaxy and then you're
trying to get to the center of that
galaxy and then when you do something
happens and that is worthwhile seeking
out but the game doesn't end there
basically and you can continue to play
the game forever but there's a big part
of us that does not want to like talk
and say this is what you must do you
know we're going to pour a lot into this
game and we're already pouring a lot
into it I would like the opportunity to
see it fully realized right and I would
like to have the level of success that
that makes that possible everyone hates
it it stinks to place up and we probably
won't keep working on all right we'll do
that day zero patch and run away when I
think about what it must be like to play
no man sky if you'll allow me to be
reductive I think about exploring and
Skyrim or a less rigid version of FTL
your core goal is clear about how you
prepare for it and how you allow
yourself to get distracted along the way
meaning your experience is unique to you
alone but not like other games there's
something else at play here the scale of
the universe in Skyrim when you saw
solitude for the first time when you
spotted your first dragon or explored a
deep cave you were struck by its beauty
but you also knew that millions of other
players around the world probably were
to imagine if you're the first person to
see it perhaps the only person to ever
see it tomorrow on the next big game we
tackle what the epic scale of no man's
sky could mean for gameplay and we
premiered the development tools that
built an entire universe
you
you